- President Kennedy's legacy calls us
to focus on fighting for
the future that can be,
not holding on to a past that never was.
We know that the towns, the cities,
the counties, the state, the countries
that wanna attract people, create jobs,
grow wealth, give our kids
a better life than we had
will be places that are open, inviting,
inclusive, tolerant, entrepreneurial,
creative, healthy, culturally
rich, authentic, and smart.
You see, the future does not belong
to the place that closes its
door to those seeking refuge.
The future does not belong to a country
that closes its heart to our
Hispanic brothers and sisters
who, in New Orleans, helped us rebuild.
The future does not belong to a place
that bans our Muslim neighbors
who assert their constitutional rights
of religious liberty, to
choose his or her faith,
or the country that rejects those
who have the right to be
free from discrimination
because of who they choose to love.
The future does not belong to a country
who closes itself off to
young African American
boys and girls who still feel
left out of the mainstream,
and it certainly does
not belong to a place
where working-class men
and women in the heartland
who feel left behind by an
economy that feels rigged
and rewards only a few, who every day,
fight the temptation
to turn on each other,
because they know in their marrow
that diversity is this
nation's calling card
to the cause of freedom and liberty.
This notion is central to
our American aspiration.
It is central to who we are as a people.
And it is why it is so important
that we have to confront our history.
We cannot change history,
but we can surely, surely learn from it.